in a year with a new halo game coming
out you'd expect to see a lot of halo
and microsoft's press conference at
gamecom and we saw a decent amount of
halo I don't know if I would call it a
lot but an interesting tease towards the
end of the show we'll get to that in a
minute first off we're gonna talk about
halo 5 Guardians join me on the couch
it's Alex new house and Mike McCarty hi
guys okay hey hot halo yes halo yeah
yeah so we're both big Halo fans yeah
coolios uh showed the new map today
Colosseum mm-hmm I mean they do this all
the time when they show a new map and
people like myself get excited about it
but it did it looked like kind of like
one of those a lot of varying sight
lines they're kind of places where you
could see like power weapons like the
sniper rifle coming to play but also a
lot of close quarters which is kind of
always good too but it's also very
vertical map and you know they showed
them and playing capture the flag so
they were kind of making use of the
jetpack in the ground pound yeah it's
one of these uh it feels like a close
quarters map and you know watching it
because the players are so focused on
the corridors and the platforms and sort
of that they're kind of place fear you
don't I don't know it's a little tough
for me cuz I don't get to see like the
grandeur of the map you know there's no
like halo arcing up in the distance or
man cannons shooting you across the big
map I sort of I like I'm itching to see
some bigger maps out of halo but we saw
a little bit of those are in war zone
demos at e3 this year and so here we're
seeing a close match between some
eSports folks and one of the notable
things here and sort of halo 5s very
what's the word I'm searching for
concerted push into eSports they were
like huge emphasis on it is this a
spectator mode that's showing you the
silhouettes of all the guys around yeah
and I think this is huge like with a
first person shooter if you're trying to
make a push in the eSports you
desperately needed a spectator mode to
make that thing worth it you know with
any sort of sports event or even you
know let's say dota league of legends
they all have those like over the top or
you know the the sort of most of that
you see everything that's happening on
the field you really need to have that
sort of perspective to know where you
are on the map like who's around you if
you're watching it if you're if you're
trying to you know follow it and i think
the silhouettes an interesting trick
because so much of the satisfaction I
get from playing halo multiplayer is the
mind game of
and you know i think you're around the
corner are you gonna push are you going
to try to grenade and hold off are you
just going to crouch and wait so like as
a spectator it's not always easy to have
that kind of sense for what's going on
on the flow of the map especially when
you're hopping between perspectives so
getting that sort of at a glance info to
like give you a little bit more to work
with give you a little bit better
understanding what's going on I think
it's a good move they're also trying to
bring a lot of attention to the eSports
mode by ass offering up a lot of money
million-dollar prize pool for the halo
World Championships it's not quite the
biggest prize pool in eSports not really
by a longshot with the International
going on right now but what do you think
I think this sort of pushed for halo 5
eSports is gonna going to bear fruit you
guys optimistic I'm optimistic yeah i
think you know halo 5 definitely seems
like of any halo it doesn't it seems
like it's the most welded design for
eSports I think it'll you know like you
said the prize pool is a million dollars
maybe maybe a little more I think I
think it's million okay but you know you
have the International which is like 17
right now this week but I think it's a
good start at least it gets my hopes up
because halo 5 looks great from what
I've seen what I played so far and I'm
excited to see what that tournament can
do for would you watch some competitive
halo yeah definitely would you go to a
stadium in Seattle to watch some
competitive halo mmm yeah not yeah that
one thing all right so halo 5 Guardians
actually not the biggest halo news to
come out of gamescom that honor goes to
the conference ending announcement
reveal of halo wars 2 halo wars the RTS
sort of scion of the Halo franchise came
out in 2009 I lukewarm reception at best
I would have to say but what do you guys
think we did you have some halo wars fun
okay I am so excited for this is by far
my favorite reveal of Microsoft's games
Calvin I absolutely loved the original
Halo Wars I was that guy who was like
you know that is like I'm you know in a
9 level game like I loved it really and
yet it I I thought it was would you like
about it I thought it was the best
example of an RTS on a console mom
that's existed so far i also just you
know I loved that it was an RTS in the
hill at university or something so novel
especially then when I think it was
bungie was developing Halo 3 ODST at
that point or just released it and it
was just a really novel way to you know
get something new into the halo formula
and so I just thought that the campaign
was awesome i didn't really play much
multiplayer but the story missions were
really good and it was nice seeing other
a glimpse in this story and so that was
course developed by ensemble studios
this one is helmed up by Creative
Assembly better known well you know
known for their Total War series and you
know if anyone's got some RTS chops it's
these guys but in terms of the RTS on
console that's a new new thing of course
worth remembering that this is for Xbox
one and Windows 10 yeah yeah and it's
interesting because like Alex said I
think they did a really ensemble did a
really good job of you know mapping the
controls to a controller as opposed to
keyboard and mouse mm-hmm it'll be
interesting to see how someone that has
so much experience with RTS Creative
Assembly will handle it I think they'll
do I think they'll do a good job and I'm
interested to see how they can expand
the scope because halo wars unlike Alex
I didn't like it as much I think I liked
it for about five hours I really like
that it gave us another look at you know
the early days of the human covenant war
because this was a prequel to halo
combat evolved so you get to see a new
side of that but also I think that after
a few hours of playing you kind of see
everything the game has to offer at
least I felt like that so I'm interested
to see how creative assembly might
create a longer lasting experience maybe
because it looks promising i'm pretty
excited it could also be interesting to
see you know with creative Assembly's
work with total war which has massive
you know huge scale battles what they do
with that and potentially if they you
know expand the scope of the Halo Wars
battles could be super interesting
here's hoping also uh brutes you guys
like to see those hairy bastards back
again a lot of them all right all the
time oh yeah alright that's coming out
in fall 2016 who knows if it'll land
there or not but that's again coming up
for Xbox one and Windows 10 an
interesting question here I think is is
this the halo experience that people are
going to get on pc microsoft is so much
about halo being this flagship series
this really you know obviously it is a
pillar of their exclusive studio do you
think halo wars is enough halo on the pc
or do you guys
want to see more I'd like to see more I
think it's a good start I mean I know
that sounds like the easy question but I
think it's a good idea to kind of gauge
how much people want because I think you
know that it is a big it's in demand on
PC and everything but I'm excited to see
how they could use this as a springboard
to kind of get into more and you know
there are a few genres i can think of
that would be better suited for pc than
RTS i think it I think it's a good start
as well like what they have so far on
the pc is Spartan strike and Spartan
assault and then halo 1 and so if they
really push you know start a push into
like here's a fully fledged game here's
something that we know that fans of the
Halo series as a whole will like then I
think that's a good start into something
you know expanding more all right folks
let us know what you think about the
halo wars 2 announcement in the comments
below one of the biggest surprises to
come out of gamescom 2015 up next we're
going to take a look at the doom trailer
just released for gamescom special and
then we're back here to talk more
microsoft press conference games stick
with us